je sais qu est-ce que certains d'entre
vous arrive de portée du cachemire
maintenant les prix sont devenus assez
bas oui nathalie même sens le marché il
ya des pronos également oui parce que
c'est vrai que les prix se sont
démocratisés mais cette démocratisation
des prix bas ça a des conséquences et
capital nous explique tout cela en
visitant cet élevage plusieurs animaux
attirent notre attention
il présente de larges blessures sur les
flancs ou sur le dos l'ouvrier la paix
n'y ait trop fort et la peau est parti
avec ça doit faire mal
oui une plaie encore vive alors que le
peignage a eu lieu six mois plus tôt
dans cette vidéo une cinquantaine
d'ouvriers peignent les animaux à la
chaîne pour accroître la productivité
nathalie qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors en 2011 il y avait quand même
entre 60 et 70 millions de chèvre qui
produisait du cachemire contre 15000
seulement 20 ans plus tôt c'est à dire
que la demande est tellement forte qu'on
s'est mis à produire comme cela est
actuellement la chine produit 75 % du
cachemire brut mondial
une réaction data lié à ces images avec
moi quand je vois l'image là quand je
vois le petit chinois là j'ai juste
envie de lui arracher la tête lui
arracha la chine oui hélas oui d'accord
je n'ai pas la tête on ne sait pas ce
qu'ils ressentent ce qu'on fait c'est
honteux
où ça fait mal est-ce qu'on est
responsable un petit peu parce qu'à mes
besoins la consommation ont tout le
monde le cachemire cachemires à bas prix
est-ce que c'est pas mal mieux ça
rejoint le débat ou cv comme et sur le
gavage des oies pour le pour le pour le
foie d'oie les conditions de l'abattage
des bêtes en abattoir qui ne m'empêche
pas de manger du foie gras et manger de
la viande aurait effectivement c'est
scandaleux
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça
effectivement le problème reste posé
donc moi ça ça me choque mais très
honnêtement j'achète j'achète du
cachemire rêve et c'est pas ça qui va
empêcher
hélas et la fin mais on n'a pas besoin
de cachemire pour vivre moi quand je
vois ces images là franchement ça me
hérisse le poil là je suis pas dans la
démagogie
moi j'ai vu les images tout à l'heure
voir ses chèvres en train de crier avec
les images sont impressionnantes mais
après il faut pas non plus jeter le bébé
avec l'eau du bain
il n'y a pas forcément que des gens qui
maltraitent mais la lave assurons les
chais mais là il était attaché entre
elles avec les cornes oui ça fait rien
je veux dire par révulser vraiment à
vomir après moi il m'arrive de faire les
mêmes bruxelles et de ne pas souffrir
privé france voilà donc on n'est pas là
pour parler de ça mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas possible il va falloir à un
moment donné qu'on arrête d'acheter du
cachemire qui vient de chine
en tout cas savoir d'où il provient
effectivement et donc de quel est l'âge
et paie pas un élevage va pas se mentir
le cachemire c'est quand même pour une
élite s'il vient pas de chez nous coûte
une blague en tout cas très bien patiné
qui coûte très cher effectivement on est
on est à peu près sûr que l'animal n'a
pas été mal mais la bonne remarque que
la raison c'est la traçabilité
effectivement sur jimmy oui je vous sens
dubitatif quand même un peu hypocrite
pour faire du cachemire faut tondre des
chèvres ben voilà on le découvre on peut
de l'ordre de faciliter les conditions
dans lesquelles ces faits ne faut pas
être étonné parce qu'on veut forcément
du pas cher et on veut quelque chose de
qualité
tu as évoqué l'histoire du foie gras
c'est la même chose on veut du foie gras
souvent et pas cher et bien si on veut
du cachemire beaucoup et pas cher
forcément derrière il ya toute une
chaîne de production qui fait qu'on peut
pas acheter local on obligé d'acheter en
chine on peut pas bien traiter les
animaux
donc il faut pas la volonté nenê
nouvelle ce n'est pas la priorité de 100
euros que vous trouvez le même qu'on
veut d'ici du cachemire cinq fois moins
cher vous doutez bien que les conditions
d'élevage la manufacture la chaîne de
production
les employés la localisation n'est
absolument pas la même donc il faut se
réveiller ce vendredi soir on est ma
musique avenir très cher parce qu'on
sait que c'est qu'on peut se le
permettre il sait très bien où ça on
assume on dit oui ma ces images ne me
dérange pas y en a le droit
c'est pas interdit d'acheter du
cachemire qui vient de chine même si ce
cachemire a été fait dans des conditions
horribles
ce n'est pas interdit par la législation
française donc faut assumer pour arrêter
ces pudeurs de gaz et en disant oh là
c'est vrai que c'est malsain avec
derrière caen et sochaux corde mais les
gens derrière qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire parce qu'ils veulent du y veulent
forcément saviez comme tout le monde
parce qu'il ya une pression on veut
forcément tout savoir des habits de
qualité et on veut absolument à acheter
du café des images franchement autant on
voit les images des abattoirs moi c'est
la première fois que je ne savais pas
qu'on maltraiter les chefs pour faire du
cachemire c'est aussi parce qu'ils n'ont
mené par des rivalités cela ce qu'ils
vont en généralité heureusement
heureusement que semblait le
déraillement mais d'accord mais
malheureusement il ya désormais comme
dans les abattoirs il ya certainement
des amateurs où ça se passe mieux que
d'autres bien sûr et moi c'est des
images que j'avais jamais vu
donc voilà c'est bien aussi qu'on les
voie pour prendre conscience qu'est ce
que vous voulez bien natalie jouen
j'étais tout à fait d'accord avec elle
normalement je suis d'accord non mais je
souhaiterais dire mais c'est ça
exactement mois ci c'est la première
fois que génial me supportent voyez ok
ça se passe bien les deux
aux copines voyez aller passer des
week-ends chez les deux très bien
[Applaudissements]